el huracán laboran nuestros corazones
están con ustedes el presidente va a
continuar apoyándolos en cada paso del
camino y como siempre hacemos los
estadounidenses la nación se unirá para
ayudarles a reconstruir sus hogares sus
negocios y sus comunidades para que sean
más fuertes y más resilientes que nunca
antes
fue hace cuatro años yo les presenté a
un constructor a un empresario a un
outsider y al nominado del pueblo el
presi para presidente de los eeuu esta
noche estoy aquí ante ustedes como la
hija orgullosa de el presidente del
pueblo
es nuestro comandante en jefe
el defensor del trabajador
estadounidense defensor del sentido
común y la voz de los hombres y mujeres
olvidados del país el presidente y mi
padre donald trump
[Aplausos]
esta noche quiero decirles y contarles
de el líder que yo conozco y lo que yo
quisiera que todos pudieran ver quiero
contarles la historia de un presidente
que está luchando por ustedes desde el
amanecer hasta el anochecer cuando se
han ido las cámaras se apagan los
micrófonos y las decisiones realmente
cuentan cuando el javits y yo nos fuimos
a vivir con nuestros hijos a washington
no sabíamos que nos enfrentábamos pero
nuestros hijos les encantó desde el
principio mi hijo joseph
les dio una réplica en lego de la casa
blanca el presidente aún la muestra en
la oficina oval justo ahí para que pueda
mostrarle a los líderes mundiales que
tiene los mejores nietos del mundo y
estoy de acuerdo
en los últimos cuatro años hemos
aprendido mucho he visto que en
washington es fácil que los políticos
puedan sobrevivir porque evitan las
peleas duras no podía creer que tantos
políticos realmente prefieren quejarse
de un problema en lugar de arreglarlo
quedé en shock al ver que la gente
dejaba los retos sin cumplir para poder
atacar al otro lado y poder hablar del
mismo tema en la próxima elección pero
yo no vino a washington para hacer lo
mismo el vino a washington por una sola
razón hacer a eeuu grande de nuevo
[Aplausos]
mi padre tiene convicciones fuertes él
sabe en que cree y dice lo que piensa ya
sea que estén de acuerdo con él o no
siempre saben en donde se ubica
reconozco que el estilo de comunicación
de mi padre no es para el gusto de todos
y sé que sus tweets pueden ser un poco
sin filtro pero los resultados son los
que hablan por sí mismos
[Aplausos]
respecto a lo que cree y ha hecho que
tanto yo como tantos estadounidenses
miremos nuestras propias convicciones y
nos preguntemos qué es lo que defendemos
qué tipo de eeuu queremos dejar a
nuestros hijos yo estoy más segura que
nunca antes que queremos un futuro donde
nuestros hijos puedan creer en la
grandeza estadounidense queremos en la
sociedad donde cada niño pueda vivir en
una comunidad segura e ir a una gran
escuela de su elección
queremos una cultura donde las
diferencias de opinión y el debate sean
alentados y no cancelados donde las
autoridades sean respetadas donde la
diversidad sea celebrada y dónde
la gente desde cualquier origen o credo
pueda alcanzar su potencial dado por
dios este es el futuro que mi padre
trabaja por construir todos los días
[Aplausos]
construir después de todo es lo que ha
hecho toda su vida es admirado
y ha trabajado en cientos de
construcciones
pero ha sido una profunda experiencia
para l para mí ver a los trabajadores
venir hacia él con una lágrima en los
ojos y agradecerle por ser la única
persona en defenderlos por su familia
por sus hijos y su futuro a los hombres
y mujeres trabajadores del país aquí
esta noche ustedes son la razón por la
cual mi padre lucha con todo su poder
usted es una razón por la cual se lanzó
a la presidencia y ustedes son la razón
por la cual va a seguir luchando por
otros cuatro años
cómo
yo recuerdo una tarde en febrero de 2018
estábamos en la oficina oval con el
asesor económico de mi padre y el
presidente quería mantener su promesa de
renegociar los acuerdos comerciales que
habían acabado con miles de empleos de
la clase media la mayoría de los
asesores dijeron que la economía estaba
tan fuerte después de los cortes a las
regulaciones de los impuestos que no
tenía sentido hacerlo después de la
reunión cuando hablé con mi padre y lo
llevé a la residencia él me dijo la
razón por la cual esto no se ha hecho es
porque nuestros líderes no han tenido
las agallas cuando la economía estaba
bien se contentan con eso y no tienen y
siguen dejándolo para el futuro para que
sea problema de alguien más y estaban lo
correcto si mi padre no hubiese tomado
estas peleas nadie lo habría hecho en
los meses que siguieron el presidente
camps se rehusó
y quedarse con un buen trato quería un
gran trato y eso es exactamente lo que
obtuvimos
recuerdo cada vez que hablaban de los
progresos del acuerdo con méxico y
canadá decía
no dejes caer a estos campesinos que
conocí en wisconsin quiero que ellos
amen este nuevo acuerdo
hoy
en medio
de esta pandemia sin precedentes es más
claro que nunca que nuestro presidente
hizo lo correcto al tratar el tema del
comercio arreglando
y trayendo de nuevo los empleos y las
fábricas al país
[Aplausos]
mientras nuestro país se enfrenta a este
gran reto oro por las familias que han
perdido un ser querido por aquellos que
siguen luchando contra el cob y 19 y por
los trabajadores y los trabajadores de
salud que siguen en primera línea de
esta lucha el dolor y la pena la
ansiedad durante todo este tiempo es
sentida por todos he estado con mi padre
y he visto el dolor en sus ojos cuando
recibe las actualizaciones de las vidas
que se ha llevado este virus
he visto como tomadas las decisiones más
difíciles de su vida me senté con él en
la oficina oval cuando dejó cuando acabo
con él detuvo el viaje y los viajes
desde europa y acabó y tuvo que dar
marcha atrás con la economía que iba
extremadamente bien y tenía tasas de
desempleo muy bajas y tuvo que cerrarla
para salvar vidas estadounidenses
[Aplausos]
es por eso que nuestro presidente
movilizó la fuerza del gobierno y del
sector privado para producir
respiradores en cuestión de semanas para
crear el sistema de testeo más grande
del mundo y crear tratamientos y muy
pronto una vacuna mi padre no se siente
desalentado por estos pensadores la
palabra imposible simplemente lo va a
motivar él rechaza la noción de que los
más grandes logros de este país están
detrás de nosotros él cree que nada está
fuera de nuestro alcance así que lo
mejor aún está por venir
sin he visto toda mi vida como mi padre
cree en el potencial de cada individuo
más temprano hoy todos nos vimos
inspirados por los el testimonio de alex
johnson una abuela que puede sentenciada
a la vida en prisión por un crimen
relacionado con drogas y yo estaba ahí
cuando mi padre decidió comentar su
sentencia
juntos vimos a ali salir de prisión
después de cerca de 22 años y cuando fue
a abrazar a su familia y celebraron esa
reunión
mi padre se quedó callado yo podía ver
la emoción en su rostro después de un
largo silencio me dijo imagina cuántas
personas están justo en la misma
situación que alex en este momento se
convirtió en una voz para aquellos que
han sido silenciados de manera injusta
en el sistema de prisiones y el
rectificó
cuando la ley creada por bailén en el 94
que afectó principalmente a los
afroamericanos
[Aplausos]
en contra de todas las apuestas el unió
a republicanos y demócratas para aprobar
la mayor reforma del sistema de justicia
penal y apenas estamos empezando
mi padre no hizo una campaña con este
tema simplemente atacó esta injusticia
porque siente una gran compasión por
aquellos que han sido tratados de manera
injusta más que retórica tiene la
habilidad de construir consensos y
construir éxitos bipartidistas van a
acabar con las inequidades raciales del
país y nos llevarán a unirnos el
presidente camps está haciendo avanzar
los valores estadounidenses de trabajo y
familia
hace 4 años increíble yo dije que el
presidente camps iba a cumplir con las
mujeres trabajadoras el año pasado más
del 70% de todos los nuevos empleos
fueron para las mujeres
hace cuatro años les dije que mi padre
se iba a concentrar en hacer que el
cuidado infantil por asequible y en el
primer término de hecho aprobamos la
mayor financiación al cuidado infantil
ayudándole a miles de familias un gran
cuidado a un costo que pueden pagar como
parte de los recortes de impuestos en
2019 solamente nuestros créditos
fiscales viajaron 2000 dólares en los
bolsillos de 40.000 familias
estadounidenses
los políticos demócratas introdujeron un
plan para aumentar esos créditos de
impuestos pero cuando yo estaba luchando
para asegurar que esto se duplicará ni
un solo demócrata votó para aprobar esa
ley y lo hicimos de todas formas
hace cuatro años prometí que el
presidente champ iba a apoyar a las
madres en la fuerza laboral en su primer
año firmó en ley
el 1er
crédito fiscal para
que miles de estadounidenses tengan
acceso
a este beneficio hace cuatro años dije
que necesitábamos una economía que
permitiera que la gente se levantara de
nuevo durante los primeros tres años en
el cargo 72% de todos los nuevos empleos
fueron a estadounidenses que habían
estado por fuera de la fuerza laboral
[Aplausos]
hace cuatro años les dije que lucharía
con mi padre y cuatro años después aquí
estoy
muchos de los temas que mi padre ha
liderado ahora han sido temas
republicanos
mi padre escoge el sentido común donde
ellos escogen el partido mi padre escoge
al pueblo
desde el día en que tomó el juramento he
visto como mi padre se enfrenta a las
políticas fallidas del pasado y hacer lo
que ningún otro líder ha hecho
recientemente tomó una acción dramática
para recortar los precios de los
medicamentos de prescripción a pesar de
las llamadas de los hijos de las
compañías farmacéuticas ahora cuando
vemos estos
estas propagandas pagadas por estas
empresas el sonríe y me dice mira
estamos haciendo algo bien si nos están
atacando de manera tan fuerte
de spring el presidente dijo que
los cultivos estaban siendo dañados
también por el virus y le pidió el
secretario para el dub para que
encontráramos estas vegetales carne y
las llevaremos a las familias más
necesitadas en cuestión de días la
llamamos el producto creamos un programa
que ahora ha entregado más de 100
millones de comidas y los ha llevado a
las manos de familias estadounidenses
[Aplausos]
para proteger a los más vulnerables de
nosotros he trabajado junto al
presidente mientras que él ha afirmado
la ley nueve legislaciones para combatir
al tráfico humano
[Aplausos]
he estado al lado de mi padre
cuando ha recibido y se ha mantenido su
resolución y su determinación para
detener de una vez por todas las guerras
en el exterior
para cambiar el paradigma en medio
oriente tome un nuevo enfoque escuche a
líderes que por favor no moviera la
embajada de la llevara jerusalén sin
embargo el cumplió con esa promesa y que
una promesa que no fue cumplida por
otros presidentes porque él sabía que
era lo correcto
[Aplausos]
desafiando todas las expectativas hace
sólo semanas volvió a escribir la
historia haciendo un acuerdo de paz en
medio oriente
el mayor avance en un cuarto de siglo
por primera vez en mucho tiempo tenemos
un presidente que ha mostrado la
hipocresía de washington y lo odiaron
por eso para para la gente que ayuda por
no ser te ataca por no ser
convencionales pero yo te respeto porque
eres real y efectivo
nuestro presidente se rehúsa a rendir
sus creencias para cumplir con las
élites políticas para mi padre ustedes
son la élite ustedes son las únicas
personas con la cual quiere ganarse unos
puntos si estos problemas fueran fáciles
de resolver otros presidentes los
hubiesen resuelto pero no se obtienen
resultados diferentes haciendo las cosas
de la misma manera
washington no ha cambiado a de nacho
donald jones ha cambiado a washington
[Aplausos]
eeuu no necesita otro vehículo vacío que
haga lo que pide a su partido ahora más
que nunca eeuu necesita otros cuatro
años de un guerrero en la casa blanca
[Aplausos]